What's up everybody! This is Zacky from
Geek Culture and today we will be
unboxing the Star Wars - The Vintage
Collection: The Mandalorian AT-ST Raider toy vehicle.
This AT-ST Raider toy is
inspired by the vehicles in The Mandalorian.
The upcoming series premiering on Disney+ on November 12 this year.
Not much is known about the
series so far. Though we know it will
take place five years after the events
of Return of the Jedi and follows the
journey of a Mandalorian bounty hunter.
First and foremost is the
vintage-inspired packaging itself.
It features the original Kenner toys branding
Which has produced several highly recognizable
toys and merchandise
some of you may remember the action
figures from the original series of Star Wars and
and Jurassic Park.
Out of the box we
get a disassembled AT-ST and a Klatooinian AT-ST pilot.
Now not much is known
about how Klatooine and The Mandalorian fits
into the story but what we can say is that
this variant of the All-Terrain Scout Transport Vehicle
is used by a Klatooinian Raider
after the fall of the Galactic Empire.
The Klatooinian AT-ST Raider
features an opening cockpit,
articulated legs, adjustable laser cannons,
side-mounted weapon pods and moveable
command viewpoint blast shield.
This AT-ST also sports a new paint job that we
will probably see in the show.
Customized with Klatooinian decals and paintwork
fabric material and a net.
It just goes to show how
much detail it went to make this figure
and leaves us speculating for what is to come.
And it's also compatible
with 3.75-inch scale Star Wars action figures.
and what a better way than to
show it off with the figurines from the
Commemorative Edition Skywalker Saga.
These are the first wave of 3.75-inch gold
figure 2 packs in this new series.
Right out of the bat, there's a metallic foil
packaging on the print if you flip to
the back each of these boxes have their
respective prints from the prequel
trilogy; Episode 1: The Phantom Menace in 1999
which features Darth Maul and Yoda.
Episode 2: Attack of the clones in 2002,
with Mace Windu and Jango Fett, and Episode 3 Revenge of the Sith in 2005 with
Obi-Wan and Anakin Skywalker.
With that we hope you enjoyed this unboxing of the Klatoonian AT-ST Raider toy
and the figures for the Skywalker saga.
If you would like to know more about these goodies
be sure to check out the link in the
description below don't forget to slam
that subscribe button and tell us about
what you would like us to unbox next.
See you on the next one!
Until then, stay geeky!